hi Gary my name is EOS love the videos
by the way as well as this so thank you
very much for that but if in a battery
to start with thank you I wear a couple
of hats one of them is a business but
actually the question I wanted to ask
you is I've I've founded a charity for
children in Wharton in war zones in
refugee camps I'm intrigued I also AM
politically active to try and stop the
circumstances that put them in that
place and in the first place I'm
intrigued what the jab jab jab right
hook principles that could be applied
with him that paradigm would be what the
best channels would be in your view and
had have had a best user to me i you've
noticed that suddenly I said nonprofits
a couple times right because I have a
lot of passion for to some on the board
of pencils of promise which is an
organization that builds schools in in
the third-world countries and I've been
so happy that I've been able to bring my
expertise to that organization because
we're doing so much better on social
network donations there is no but as bad
as companies are as bad as big companies
are in on social networks only throwing
right hooks even worse are charities
every [ __ ] tweet is donate this for
every dollar you retweet this that I
carry we can you retweet this every
[ __ ] minute 40 times a day I have
been approached by a non-profit many
times this week to retweet for a
campaign
none of which even said hello to me
before asking me right so like you know
it's it's absurd to me the jab - jab
right hook in an NGO world is the best
you know why the jabs are the height of
emotion we want to put out pictures of
that scenario as jabs guess what you
give me enough of those pictures enough
people share them I see that you're
gonna be able to land your right hook on
me you just asked me for money with one
picture I mean the NGO space is the
worst they're they they're just so stuck
in asking for money and they need to
romance their donators